oh man so like the earth's flat and i
was like oh isn't it have you ever
touched a light bulb if if you've
touched a hot light bulb imagine one
much bigger
imagine a world where you're filming
something and someone else has to see
what's being filmed at the same time
it takes a lot of gear to run a studio
like ours we're going out and traveling
around the world for shoots all the time
i guess you could say we we kind of have
a specialized way of doing things i
don't know where i'm going with this
some of you watching this video may want
to make movies and videos yourselves but
when you look at what people are using
in the pro league it can look super
intimidating you know what you don't
need that our gear is specifically
tailored to let us get the best possible
image but with a group that is small
nimble and lets us shoot in an
affordable way all the best stuff we use
the stuff that could be really good has
a flaw and finally the stuff that you
shouldn't bother with anyways i don't
know if you're interested in the stuff
or not but uh we're gonna tell you
all right the first thing to talk about
is the camera there's a lot of different
cameras out there and honestly at this
point they're pretty much all good it
really depends on the tool you want for
the job whatever camera you're using if
it's not this it's probably not as good
the red camera this is where it all
starts this is what we use to film our
footage why is it the best two things
really quick you feeling somebody
running against the sunset the sun's
right behind them but you need to see
their face which is in shadow this
camera can get that i can screw it up on
set i can miss my exposure i can
almost soar there do everything wrong
except for focus let's be changed all
that after the fact this is generally
called a raw format red has a raw format
that is compressed it is small compared
to other raw formats and it's very
versatile second of all it's high bit
depth means when we apply filters to
this footage it doesn't destroy it
doesn't tear it apart and look all gross
and blocky if your camera it doesn't
have a high bit depth like this just
don't compare we use this because when
we color grade our footage we want it to
look nice guys the alexa come on that's
a great camera you're right it's also
twice as expensive and we're making
youtube videos so let's be real i'm just
saying there's a reason i'm not saying
like the a7 is better
it's because it's not
if you pick that pick your next favorite
we're working our way out after your
camera the lenses are the next most
important thing and we've been using the
sigma art series lenses for a few months
now almost a year
they're the best they're basically if i
had to describe them i would describe
them as high res because simply they're
so crisp and clear they allow you to
actually maximize the resolution of
whatever camera you're shooting on wait
sam what about those fancy cinema kit
lenses why are we using those aren't
those the best that's why the art series
is good and that's why we chose them is
because they've taken the same optics of
cinema series lenses and put them in a
nice little photo lens package they look
different on the outside and they act
the same on the inside in the world of
film technology and camera gear size
matters specifically smaller is better
these lenses are great they are the best
lenses i have ever used plan on using
them into the future what about this guy
that's a cannon well the reason we're
using this canon one is because it's old
and we already bought it and it costs a
lot of money and we decided to save
ourselves an extra three thousand
dollars by not getting the sigma
equivalent these little things all right
third most important thing when it comes
to your camera i'm not gonna no it's not
we have filters here which are quite
nice we've been using the tiffin filters
for a long time really really good
really high quality high enough quality
to not
make my sigmas look bad sam is the audio
guy here
in fact he was the audio guy back before
you even had a youtube channel and you
were using this microphone should i plug
it in so we can hear it no
you can hear it in every single corridor
video that's on our channel i love
sennheiser mics but we have a trusty
standby it's the audio technica at897
anyways great mic highly recommended
we've been using this for a long time
i've been using this microphone since
pre-youtube they're not getting any
better it's like the best all-purpose
shotgun microphone it's not too narrow
it's not too wide it also
has a small compartment for battery best
design so highly recommended i love
sennheiser gear we had a sennheiser
microphone go bad on us it was sad
what's that but their headphones are
great we've actually been using the
wireless pxc 550 wireless noise
canceling bluetooth headphones they're
super cool they're super comfy they're
great for planes they're great for sets
and also they're really really good for
working in an office environment where
there's a lot of boomy reverb and people
talking and doing things it helps me get
my work done when others are trying to
stop me i do half of my hearing through
these headphones and the noise
cancelling it's so good that it scares
me it makes the world so silent you can
hear your own brain promising but flawed
this is a little bluetooth bridge i got
off of amazon it's like 20 bucks the
point is not this the point is that at
some point here camera manufacturers are
gonna realize that we are in the year
2019 and they can put a dang bluetooth
chip in their cameras so i can monitor
the audio
without a freaking wire going between me
and my camera multiple bluetooth outputs
would be great so everybody can be
listening to it guys
that's what i feel like on set
headphones are freaking wired in like
it's 1995. 1995 man bad year all right
all right all right all right
the sennheiser g3 system wireless audio
been great little pack here for the back
of our boom mic this wireless system
we've been using since day one there's
just simply limits to the technology
such as uh it's a radio it's the year
2018 and we're using radios
radio transmission sometimes the signal
gets a little weak it's a little janky
well they fixed it in the g4 which is
the upgraded version of this we should
probably upgrade also uh it doesn't
provide phantom power
but the g4 series does so i guess
i guess we're kind of saying we should
upgrade to the g4 system as you can see
by the scratches the more scratches you
see on the equipment you mean that means
it's good
this table guys
okay speaking of camera stuff and
wireless technology let's talk about
monitoring this here is a small hd
monitor on a noodle of a rig ignore the
rig small hd makes great monitors the
really cool thing about them is that you
can actually apply filters to your
footage in the monitor itself so you can
see what it looks like when it's in its
final colored state and this is paired
with the nereus hd wireless bridge this
lets us have a wireless signal from the
camera to the small hd but you know what
you don't need that anymore these days
because smallhd now has it built into
their monitors if you go to their site
and check it out why use cables
well cables are super reliable would you
set up a nereus in your home if you're
going to play uh like switch
maybe if actually i would maybe step in
nereus if i had like a little laptop
station and a little nice table next to
the couch and i wanted that to
wirelessly broadcast the tv that sounds
like a cool idea to me just imagine that
you're shooting something with more than
one person imagine a world where you're
filming something and someone else has
to see what's being filmed at the same
time what about what about professional
cameras we're going you're a pro but
you're on the go
gopro cameras super over engineered
these days i hate to say it one out of
two of them break except for the
sessions the sessions are the promise of
what the gopro thought it could be the
session gets our hearty endorsement for
the best action camera 100 100 1
hundreds hey how are you going to film
your scene if it's too dark
i i i would probably just wait until
it's light
there are only four lights that you need
to know about to shoot videos only four
and we're gonna tell you what they are
right now light number one a panel light
this is the best panel light on the
market this is the light panels astro it
gets really bright it lets you change
colors between tungsten and daylight
these leds don't have just color
spectrums these pretty much perfectly
match actual chunks of light bulbs and
actual sunlight lots of other lights can
do this but they can't do it or
replicate these uh color temperatures so
accurately also the ballast is attached
to the light so it's all in one package
convenient and portable number two light
number two
the 120 series from aputure so these
aperture led lights are really nice and
they do something that the astra does
not which is focus the light they have
these fresnel lenses attached to them
incredible these things are precise they
give you nice clean clean shadows and
they come in both daylight and tungsten
these are on every single set that
requires lights now there's other things
we need out of lights though one thing
is color
and these are some really funny little
lights we got these from b h these are
the luxely cello lights and these things
run off of little sony batteries but
what's incredible is that they can go
across the entire color spectrum that
moth video that we just released i use
this light and it's a little baby cousin
version for nearly
every single shot we no longer need to
carry a box of gels we no longer need to
keep gloves on our hands we don't need a
special person just to make sure people
don't get killed by our lights yes
there's one final light
that you need to be aware of i
legitimately don't know which light
sam's going to point out because we
prepped this and i actually do not know
the fourth and final light
fits in the palm of my hand
oh cool
these guys
all right these are the m9s from aputure
they have a slightly bigger brother but
these things are incredible because so
frequently you find yourself in a
situation where you want a little light
coming from a little place you want
something that's the size of a business
card i love these things every single
shot you see on this youtube channel has
one of these m9s right next to the lens
sam just went over the four essential
lights that you need but you know what
this
generally speaking the bigger the area
of your light the softer more gentle it
looks
and people just like that better don't i
look good right now i do look good right
now
now i look great because i have a giant
aerial light i think it's the falconized
cloth led light right here
falconized flex
this light has a fatal fly this light is
hecka clunky and hecka janky look at
this look at this giant freaking box i
have to drop on my stand with a freaking
plastic loop and then have a long wire
going up to the light and another long
wire going down to another box it's not
even on the ground it's all that pink
tape for what's that pink tape for it's
pink tape here is to have us not use the
battery port because it killed one of
our batteries
[Music]
the other thing is this rig here kind of
falls apart i think this in and of
itself the idea of a cloth led light is
beautiful and honestly screw throwing up
giant bounce boards on like six c stands
with clamps that just get knocked over
by the wind screw putting on giant soft
boxes on your lights this is how you
should be doing soft boxes if you want
to be a future man like me
it's actually a flexible like panel
because that i think you keep saying
that but you gotta see it to get it
it's just cloth on the inside
like what well it's not a raid right now
it's on a rig well basically it's
show it
rip it apart rip it
apart we need it for filming
look
look see it's bendable
so what makes it special is that it's
bendy see look at that i can just like
and flex it and curl it up like that
it's incredible it's great for packing
things up and transporting them because
you know what you got to get to and from
a film set at some point
this could be great
i wish more light companies are making
giant panels like this because rather
than to deal with a flexible material
out of flexible material because i would
love to be able to drop blankets on my
wall and have to be a giant soft box
rather than having to deal with a ton of
rigging or make the ceiling of your car
its own light source that'd be cool too
despite all its issues though we've been
using this light a lot all the photos
you see of the merchandise on the
corridor store quarter digital dot store
is lit by just this light quarter
digital dot store quarter digital dot
store oh we got a url
let's talk about batteries with real big
batteries macho batteries like this so
we have anton bauer batteries there's
also other batteries we have as well but
the thing is
these batteries this battery technology
is totally changing in the game because
these are basically giant power banks
that can power anything from a light to
your camera to your monitor anything
else and have it last for multiple hours
you can even charge your phone because
they have usb ports on them
modern technology wow what good is all
this gear if you have no way to hold it
up right we don't just set our cameras
on the ground do we no we put them uh
sometimes sometimes on the table
so once again we come back to this
rubber limited rubbermaid lifetime
uh
table quarter digital dot store no
actually specifically
first things first the tripod
everybody's a good tripod for the gear
this is a sackler tripod i think this is
like the hd something or other they have
different versions now because it's made
out of carbon fiber so it's super light
i can hold it up with one arm you know
it's also cool i can be a one-man
operation pop this open extend the leg
all three levels set it up and pop it
closed i'm good to go that is beautiful
that's what i need a tripod i don't need
fuss i don't need must i just need an
easy efficient system that can do with
one person once again
just look at the wear and tear on this
thing
that means it's a good product i'm not
going to show you how it works or show
it in use but i really like these uh
zune cranes the iu and don't use gimbals
too frequently anymore but when we do
the zhiyun cranes are really really nice
there's a lot of really crappy handheld
gimbals on the market but the zhiyun
cranes are not one of them put the
camera on there you turn it on and it
works now the ronin
the new ronin s
yeah so the new ronin-s haven't really
used it too much looks really good maybe
we'll upgrade to it maybe it is better
probably it is better we do have other
gimbals they stay in the closet
yeah let's go old school here i mean
this is too big to set up so we left it
in the closet but this is where chrome
cuts the b-roll of us using this we
found sliders are for chumps the liebeck
jib arm and track by far the best thing
you can get if you want smooth versatile
camera motion or cinematic movements
this is better than any gimbal just
better than any tripod by itself this is
better than any slider it makes all
these things obsolete it is rock solid
it's super basic technology and it will
never let you down computer time let's
talk about let's talk about electronics
all right so there's computers there's
good computers and bad computers
generally computers that you build
yourself fall into the good computers
and what's even better than self-built
computers are the ones we have from
puget systems they are our most powerful
computers in the studio they are the
workhorses that do a lot of our editing
and rendering and all the cool
processing the thing is those guys are
really good at outfitting them and
they're really good at helping us out
with little customer support issues when
there are
issues which is very rarely those are
really really good
now in between good and bad lies a
category called could be good and those
are the google chromebooks uh as you
guys probably saw recently we did some
stuff with them hi i'm nico hey i'm sam
having our chromebooks on hand has
actually been a fantastic addition to
our workflow
i guess it's not even could be good we
want to like them more but there's two
main issues
one high latency ipad pros have very
very low latency and since these are
technically touch screen tablets too
they should have low latency when you're
doing drawing and things like that oh
the space bar on mine is freaking janked
up
and your keyboard should not be the
first thing to fail
how else are you gonna use it if your
keyboard you know like plug in an
external keyboard
but i that being said i still carry it
everywhere i go because i find it so
useful since it's smaller than a laptop
so
you know we like them but we could like
them more this is what i do most of my
riding on in the studio it actually
works great for that i think google
needs to hone in on what exactly they're
trying to do with the chromebook they're
going for a high-end laptop that cost a
thousand dollars
i don't think they quite got it they're
going for a great little handy netbook
for writing they basically got it but a
thousand dollars is too steep for that
brutal reviews nico gets harsh watch out
angry nico you don't want to see him
angry
tell me about origin
i know
well there's a reason we're working with
puget now instead of origin
hey you guys want to see the best poll
you can possibly get your remote that's
this the k k-tec boom pole i don't
remember what it's called but it's the
carbon fiber one you might think you
don't need a boom pole but you're wrong
because sound is like one of the most
important things from video you could
have nothing on the screen and just some
good sound and you're all set this is
the best
dang boom pole we have ever used it's
super light like super light let's go
for a second sam look at that look how
light that is how long is that it's long
enough we have touched the top of sam's
head
22 or three feet yeah we actually this
is strong enough to hold that softbox
light which is yeah this is uh if you
ever want to get a boom pole this is the
one to get
in quarters 2018 gear video
we would be remiss not to grab the
camera and turn it around these boys oh
hi
they do more filming than we do get over
here you need to wear these so that way
the microphone doesn't break on you and
you don't know
it requires both because it will just go
to mono sometime
uh video micro
by rode really great really small
phantom powered by dslr sound quality
passable cheap 70 bucks problem
uh they died after a year
there are better road mics out there but
they also cost a lot more this tripod is
something that uh that we
don't always use on the corridor crew
channel we use a lot especially when
traveling but benro
i don't remember the actual model but
it's a travel one great it's one of
these classic tripods they're like this
you know these ones right yeah the
shitty part about these kind of tripods
is you can't level the head and you
always have to
like adjust the leg to get it the best
thing about benro is they've solved that
problem for every single model some type
of micro bowl head at the top to just
adjust it right there
and it's done all the time it's amazing
it's super lightweight also i can just
now it's spiked ready for grass
and now it's ready for your uh living
room or kitchen i just need a model pad
this takes a little bit but you know
what
that's worth it yeah you can actually
take the head off of this and put it
onto here piece of gear i swear by is
this little fish that sam printed me
to hold all the memory cards guys guys
guys guys guys i forgot to mention this
3d printing pretty handy and you want to
get into 3d printing and you don't want
to have to fuss with it ultimaker 3
brought me into the 3d printing game
when previously i was like i did not
have the time to learn how to do it
shout out over for the ultimaker 3. oh
matter hackers
other guys to go to if you want to get
one so nico so nico something that we
use in every single meeting every single
monday for the last what two years
can't go wrong
made out of maple it's made out of maple
wood and every time a meeting starts
every time a meeting ends
the sigma lens oh this whole thing this
whole thing the thing that you're
holding as well yeah we shoot everything
on these they're the adds canon adds
they shoot max
1080p
60 frames per second we're shooting 60
frames but we edit and release in 30
frames per second what's great about
them is that we've used we've used them
so much so we're super efficient with
them most important thing when it comes
to a camera
is it doesn't matter if you have the
best camera it matters that you know
what camera you're using maybe i can use
that camera for longer if you have a
battery extender which we it's so great
it's cam oh it's a canon one no wait
canon's is 300 this is a 70 dollar one
from amazon yeah like the old laura
croft about it you can like have one in
your pocket
empty and then
put it right in let's see let's say
canon batteries are too expensive for
you right
it comes with
the ability to put double lid
oh that's like so jank this feels so
small now 10 to 20 because wide lenses
are amazing and then we want fancy shots
we use this 18 to 35 1.8 sigma or we
just grab a macro lens from the corridor
case
little lights as you saw on top i'm sort
of janky rig that changes every couple
the one the one on that camera is way
better you can see it now it's amazing
ads at the best camera
out there
for what for one yeah why are you using
the 80d
it's cheap
yes exactly one big factor that made us
choose this was
well at the time of us choosing it about
two years ago right yeah the the the
face tracking and autofocus it helps
it's really solid you know right now
yeah we don't always use it
but when we do use it it's great it's
great nick what is your favorite piece
of gear
my favorite piece of gear that we use in
the studio oh boy
i don't know i i guess in terms of my
daily use
it would have to be
you use this more than a camera my chair
favorite piece of gear in the whole
studio
the capture and the lens kit that might
not make sense what i just said it's a
great choice it's called it's
technically just a lens holster peak
designs capture and then lens kit
they're two separate products you but
they can be used together let's take it
actually let's do a full spin we'll spin
give me the most expensive lens we have
no belts
you go around the side
i'm gonna tighten this up so
nick gracefully just put a thousand
dollar lens on this
i'm gonna put it on my belt
you're crazy so this little button
allows me to take it off otherwise it'll
be there now safety lock it by twisting
it
so now i have a lens hanging on me
wires man
see if if cameras had bluetooth
to go to headphones niko wouldn't have
just almost dropped the camera it's a
hot spot it's a hot spot
normally i'd have to use this table i'm
not going to use the table
[Music]
ready for the next shot boss
i have never felt like i want to keep
swapping lenses more
on a set so i usually have
where's the super long lens
50 to 250 millimeter lens
that i usually swap with when i'm on set
for behind the scenes with this wide
lens so i can get nice wide close-up
talking heads and then switch go run
across the field and get a nice long
b-roll shot
boom i like red bull too pretty amazing
um you can have more than one heck uh
yes we do
so i just want to put this camera away
see if i can work come on
blow this
so this is just a walk in the park if
you go to a wedding and you look at any
of the photographers this is how a
photographer looks yeah a little bit
more defeated yeah that's about it all
right i hope you enjoyed our little gear
review with attitude here but this is
not about the best gear for everybody
we'll have some links to it in the
description below
it's all about the same thing it's about
finding gear that allows you to just do
what you want to do in less time less
headaches and just i want to shoot a
scene well let's go shoot that scene hey
fun fact for all of you guys you know
the reason why mirrorless cameras stop
recording at 30 minutes it's not because
of any hardware limitation but because
there is actually an extra tax put on
cameras that can record for more than 30
minutes because they are considered
video cameras carmichael taught us that
one guys we've been trying to get one
more subscriber for the last five years
and hopefully if you're not subscribed
and you subscribe right now that one
last subscriber will be you stop letting
youtube recommend your videos and start
subscribing to them and making decisions
for yourself oh youtube's like oh we
recommend you watch this corridor crew
video because of your viewing habits
just to admit that you need to subscribe
hey jake nice to meet you yeah i love
your work thank you so much doing well
how are you guys doing convince us why
it's a good idea to be a flat earth
believer he's like oh man so like the
earth's flat and i was like oh isn't
that no no he seemed to be very adamant
about it but sometimes when nasa shoots
off rockets the reason he explodes
because they hit the glass ceiling oh
yeah we're like a terrarium